[Musique]
et avec nous Benjamin Morel très en
forme bonjour Benjamin merci d'être là
Yves très rare non moi en forme bonjour
bonjours après 10 jours de débat le
Sénat donc adopter le texte dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche à saint-paris
gagner pour la majorité sénatoriales
vous nous le direz et maintenant c'est
la question c'est une semaine décisive
qui s'ouvre pour l'exécutif qui va
devoir aller chercher les voies des
députés notamment les républicains pour
passer le texte en 49-3 c'est son
objectif mais que font ces députés les
républicains le Paris du gouvernement
peut-il être tenu vous ne direz ce que
vous en pensez d'abord on va regarder la
mobilisation dans nos régions c'est
l'actualité dans nos régions
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Marseille et on retrouve les
haut-purgate bonjour Léo merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous présidents et directeur
éditorial de La Marseillaise et Léo à
Marseille est dans la région le
mouvement de contestation ne s'éteint
pas avec des grèves et des blocages qui
continuent
absolument dans des secteurs
stratégiques je pense à la pétrochimie
au pétrole au carburant des grèves dans
trois raffineries pétroeneos Total Esso
dans notre territoire mais aussi dans
des entreprises importantes du secteur
de la Chine je pense à 9 alchimie
notamment c'est aussi le cas dans les
transports avec les cheminots qui
maintiennent leurs grèves qui auront à
se prononcer à nouveau aujourd'hui ou
encore chez les ports et doc qui se
prononceront demain et qui d'après nos
informations devraient lancer un
mouvement de grève de trois jours
continuent on a donc effet beaucoup de
secteurs qui restent mobilisés sur
l'objectif d'une reconductible c'est
également le cas de l'énergie ou les
opérations de baisse de production de se
poursuivent la centrale thermique de
Gardanne est à l'arrêt
et les opérations Robin des Bois qui
consiste à remettre le courant ou à
rendre gratuit le courant au plus
modeste et bien continue également
et Léo dans vos pages vous revenez
également sur la mobilisation de samedi
avec des témoignages de manifestants
les manifestants qui dans toute notre
zone de diffusion depuis Avignon en
passant par Marseille
Brignoles Toulon Aix-en-Provence
Arles nous disent tous à leur façon
qu'ils demandent au président de la
République de retirer ce projet qui juge
complètement illégitime au regard de la
procédure législative qui a été employée
certains d'entre eux lui demandent un
référendum mais tous lui demandent le
retrait
et à lire également l'interview du
sénateur sénateur communiste
absolument Jérémy Baki qui dénonce la
façon dont tu as été selon lui tordu le
règlement du Sénat pour faire passer ce
texte il considère que la minorité
sénatoriale représente sur cette
question l'écrasante majorité de la
nation et demande effectivement là aussi
au président de la République
d'interrompre cette fuite en avant merci
beaucoup Léo regarde la Une de La
Marseillaise aujourd'hui réforme des
retraites semaine rouge c'est à la Une
de votre journal merci beaucoup
léo-purgates d'avoir été avec nous ils
vont le voir les grèves les blocages
continuent du côté de Marseille mais pas
seulement et samedi c'est vrai que la
mobilisation était moindre dans les rues
de France est-ce que c'est temporaire ou
est-ce qu'on assiste à un essoufflement
de la mobilisation liée au vote du
textement
ça marque pas quand même très très
nettement ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on disait que il y avait une
incertitude sur le la rue comment elle
allait se comporter et puis que malgré
tout la procédure parlementaire allait
aller de soi et que ça allait passer
comme ça bah finalement ça m'aperçoit
que le suspense et davantage au
Parlement que dans la rue sincèrement je
pense que dans la rue les chiffres le
montrent ça ça s'essouffle
j'ai l'impression que les Français quand
même s'en remettent au Parlement d'une
certaine façon et maintenant le suspense
et le vrai suspense il est au Parlement
entre la commission mixte paritaire
l'examen au Sénat après et surtout à
l'Assemblée nationale donc là c'est là
que ça va se jouer donc
j'ai plutôt tendance à penser que le
suspense est là et que ça veut pas dire
pour autant que je dirais le
mécontentement populaire qui a pu être
exprimé pendant ces deux mois de de
manifestations et bien se dissipera et
il peut se reporter sur autre chose bien
sûr on va évidemment parler de la partie
parlementaire et de la commission mix
paritaire mais sur la mobilisation
Benjamin comment vous vous voyez est-ce
que c'est un essoufflement est-ce que le
vote du texte au Sénat en tout cas va
affaiblir la mobilisation ou est-ce
qu'au contraire elle peut la radicaliser
la mobilisation relativement faible
samedi mais elle suit un mardi qui était
plutôt important en termes de
mobilisation donc vous avez un effet
roulant c'est à dire que les
manifestations des samedis ont
principalement pour objectif d'amer dans
les manifs des gens qui ne viennent pas
la semaine donc là c'est traditionnel
dans la dans la stratégie des syndicats
je suis pas sûr soit extrêmement habile
justement parce qu'ensuite on commente
des chiffres en baisse ce qui est
surtout important pour le mouvement
social c'est le nombre de grévistes et
la capacité de blocage et l'échec du
mouvement social aujourd'hui il est
plutôt là il y a certes une grève
relativement large mais dans les
secteurs qui sont les secteurs bloquants
et bien entre guillemets ça roule et
parce que ça roule et bien pour les
grévistes aujourd'hui c'est relativement
problématique parce que dans un bras de
fer vous avez besoin de deux choses une
opinion qui suit elle suit une manière
structurelle donc là pour le mouvement
social il y a pas de problème et ensuite
une capacité de blocage notamment dans
les transports les raffineries
aujourd'hui elle n'existe pas ce qui ne
permet pas un bras de fer et ce qui fait
que en effet la possibilité de faire
trembler et les parlementaires et le
gouvernement quant au conséquences
potentielles d'un mouvement qui
perdurerait après le vote de la réforme
n'est pas aujourd'hui une option qui
apparaît comme étant privilégié même si
on n'est pas tout à fait à l'abri et
d'une radicalisation et d'un
élargissement du mouvement à d'autres
revendications notamment de pouvoir
d'achat auquel cas ça devient une autre
paire de manche pour le moment pas de
gros blocage mais il y a une grève des
éboueurs notamment à Paris à 5000 tonnes
de déchets dans les rues de la capitale
et est-ce que ça c'est dangereux pour un
gouvernement quand les éboueurs se
mettent en grève
tout est dangereux pour un gouvernement
vous savez c'est souvent
ça ça part et ça ça se développe que ça
se répand sans que personne ne crie gare
et qu'on s'en aperçoit pas effectivement
bon ça peut avoir des conséquences
importantes j'ai cru comprendre que il y
avait encore 48 ans de grève des
éboueurs dans les grandes villes et
notamment à Paris
on verra mais
c'est sûr que ça ça dit du pays qui va
pas très bien quoi ça c'est évident
qu'il est dans un état
qui est un état de nervosité important
on va parler de ce qui s'est passé au
Sénat Alex puisque le vote de la réforme
des retraites ça y est il a eu lieu au
Sénat c'est un Paris gagné pour la
droite du Sénat d'abord sur la forme
gagner sur la forme puisque après les
l'échecs des débats l'Assemblée
nationale est bien la droite du Sénat
voulait absolument aller au bout de
l'examen de ce texte et face à une
gauche sénatoriale qui avait l'objectif
inverse c'est à dire
changer les débats et éviter un vote
final et bien la majorité de droite et
du centre du Sénat à utiliser toutes les
armes réglementaires pour accélérer la
discussion et c'était sans compter sur
l'aide du gouvernement dans la dernière
ligne droite de ces 10 jours de débat
puisque le gouvernement le rappelle
avait des cloches vendredi la procédure
dite du vote bloquée l'article 44 3 de
la Constitution ce qui a contraint à les
sénateurs à un vote unique sur
l'ensemble de cette réforme des
retraites et a permis de faire aboutir
l'examen de ce texte au Sénat ou la
satisfaction du président du Sénat
général archet je crois que le Sénat a
rempli sa mission constitutionnelle
des avant l'ouverture des débats j'avais
dit que je souhaitais vraiment
profondément que nous ayons un débat aux
alliions au bout du débat et au
Parlement après le temps du débat on
délibère et on vote et avec gagner sur
le fond oui parce que sur le fond et
bien la majorité de droite et du centre
du Sénat à voter la mesure qu'elle
proposait et votait depuis des années le
report de l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans
et l'accélération de la l'augmentation
de la durée de cotisation pour atteindre
43 annuités en 2027 ça c'est le cœur du
réacteur de cette réforme des retraites
et puis ensuite les sénateurs sont
tristes et de droite ont pu voter ce
qu'il considère comme des améliorations
au texte notamment sur la question des
femmes avec la surcotte de 5% sur les
pensions des maires de famille qui ont
une carrière complète et qui
travaillerait entre 63 ans et 64 ans ou
encore la création de ce CDI senior qui
doit inciter les entreprises à embaucher
des seniors un contrat qui est exonéré
de cotisations familiale voilà la droite
du Sénat qui a également et bien
modifier l'index seniors en repassant à
un index senior pour les entreprises de
plus de 300 salariés et pas un seuil de
50 salariés comme c'était demandé par
l'Assemblée nationale donc voilà les
sénateurs de droite ont vraiment mis
leur empreinte sur ce texte Benjamin
c'est un Paris gagné pour la majorité
sénatoriale de la droite et du centre
oui clairement parce que si jamais ce
texte n'était pas voté attend alors
après on peut discuter sur qu'est-ce que
c'était à temps mais il y avait pas de
commission mixte paritaire théoriquement
si vous prenez l'article 111-7 de la loi
organique on revenait au début et donc
ça faisait que tout le travail fait au
Sénat et ce texte très marqué par la
majorité sénatoriale et bien il était
réduit en poussière et du à rien et pour
le gouvernement évidemment c'était un
gros gros problème parce qu'il fallait
recommencer tout processus en revanche
là on a un texte qui porte en effet la
marque de la majorité satoriale on va
avoir une commission mixte paritaire
dans lequel la droite et le centre et
bien sont en position de force pour
imposer leur texte ne serait-ce que
parce que le groupe LR à l'Assemblée
nationale même pas le grand amour entre
ericciotti et Bruno retaillou et bien va
conditionner en grande partie son vote à
l'obtention et bien des acquis ici donc
ce faisant on a un texte qui se fait au
conditions de LR et donc pour la
majorité satoriale ça montre sa capacité
à imprimer dans le paysage sur une
réforme très très symbolique évidemment
c'est quelque chose qui est à prendre et
qui permet de repositionner ensuite des
jalons pour l'avenir Yves la droite a
imprimé sur ce texte elle a marqué ce
texte de contraintes
qui est finalement fait la réforme aussi
bien sur le contenu ou effectivement
elle a elle a grâce enfin par le Sénat
par le truchement du Sénat elle a imposé
ses vues et puis
dans le vote tout simplement dans la
procédure c'est à dire que on le voit la
commission mixte paritaire s'intéressant
quand vous avez montré sa composition
on voit que c'est la droite et le centre
qui sont qui ont la chose en main donc
on peut en parler la droite elle a
beaucoup insisté sur le fait qu'elle
avait voté sa réforme est-ce que c'est
parce qu'il y a un risque dans l'opinion
qu'elle apparaisse comme un supplétif du
gouvernement non moi je crois pas moi
j'ai jamais cru ça je pense que la
droite elle ne pouvait pas s'opposer
comme certains à droite l'ont fait
frontalement à ce à cette réforme comme
l'ont fait monsieur Pradier quelques
autres
en revanche le fait qu'elle la vote ça
veut pas dire que le joue les supplétifs
d'une certaine façon elle montre qu'au
contraire elle existe et que sans elle
bah rien ne peut se faire en tous les
cas sur ce front là deuxièmement il faut
voir une chose qui me paraît tout à fait
importante c'est que en 2027 les
compteurs seront remis à zéro
c'est-à-dire que le Président de la
République sortant ne pourra pas se
représenter et il y aura
vraisemblablement une bataille très
féroce entre ceux qui voudront lui
succéder dans le courant central
constitué de connaissance du MoDem et et
des autres
d'horizons
ce qui fait que ça laisse évidemment une
une un espace à la droite et je suis
persuadé que la droite si elle le joue
bien cette séquence qui va durer 3 ans
et bien elle a son mot à dire mais il
faut qu'elle trouve le visage la figure
l'incarnation qui la représente mais il
faut surtout pas qu'elle cherche à
se galvauder surtout pas après ça a
marqué quand même des fragilités dans
cette majorité de droite et du centre au
sein c'est à dire que on se concentre
évidemment sur le succès de Bruno
Retailleau etc mais vous avez à peu près
15% des députés LR afin destinataire et
l'air pardon qui n'ont pas voté je crois
que c'est 35 à 40% des centristes donc
on voit que sur ce sujet qui en effet
jusqu'à présent
l'unanimité visiblement dans la droite
sénatoriale lors du vote sur les PLFSS
il y avait malgré tous les fractures et
que et ben derrière l'image d'une
[Musique]
qui sont mécontents en majorité de cette
réforme des retraites et puis il y a
aussi des échéances électorales pour
certains sénateurs avec les prochaines
élections sénatoriales en septembre donc
forcément ils y pensent et ça explique
aussi la fébrilité qui est peut-être
plus profonde chez les députés les
républicains qui ont sauvé leur peau
pour ceux actuel au dernier législatives
et donc forcément qui réfléchissent à
deux fois avant de voter cette réforme
des retraites sur les sénatoriales
d'ailleurs Benjamin ce qui est en train
de se passer en ce moment sur les
sénateurs sur les sénatoriales c'est
évidemment plus limité parce que vous
avez pas le même collège électoral que
évidemment pour les élections
législatives et donc vous avez vous êtes
un peu moins je dirais en ligne directe
avec les lecteurs qui va avoir des
revendications même si les maires et les
conseils municipaux peuvent être des
relais importants donc là on est plutôt
dans une stratégie de positionnement
sachant que derrière les sénatoriales
ben il y a la course au plateau derrière
les sénatoriales vous avez
éventuellement la réforme
institutionnelle un petit peu conduire à
créer des clivages au sein même de la
majorité donc pour les sénateurs je
dirais c'est un peu déjà d'après
du Sénat un mot parce qu'on a on a
beaucoup parlé de la droite avant de
parler de la commission mix paritaire
sur la gauche
Hervé Marseille nous disait c'est un
tournant pour la gauche sénatoriale elle
est passée d'une gauche républicaine à
une gauche qui vire à la nuque c'est
aussi votre analyse oui mais je pense
que c'est pas il faut pas non plus
être trop définitif là-dessus je pense
que la gauche
au Sénat a cherché à exister
elle a haussé le ton mais on est quand
même assez loin quand on écoute monsieur
Cannet et quelques autres on est quand
même assez loin de ce que font de ce qui
se passe à l'Assemblée nationale donc il
y a eu une espèce d'affirmation mais on
est resté quand même c'était de c'est
c'est jamais sorti je dirais d'une épure
assez classique quand même oui j'aurais
pas fait de Patrick Kanner l'avatar
saturiel de Louis Boyard si vous voulez
non c'est à dire que on a en terme
constitutionnel par exemple
c'est-à-dire pas grand chose au
téléspectateur mais on a inventé dans le
cas du la pratique du règlement
sénatorial ce qu'on appelle les
recevabilité en bloc ce qui vous permet
de déclarer recevable plein
d'amendements qui ont fait le son mais
qui ben au regard de l'obstruction bah
fait que le Conseil constitutionnel
passe l'éponge c'était inventé dans les
années 90 donc vous voyez que
l'obstruction au Sénat l'obstruction y
compris massive c'est pas d'hier et que
les méthodes pour détourner
l'obstruction c'est pas non plus dire
soit quoi on a assisté n'est pas si
exceptionnel que ça seulement là
évidemment ça a été extrêmement commenté
extrêmement médiatisé et vu au diapason
de ce qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée
nationale en réalité il y a rien de neuf
sous le soleil effectivement la gauche
sanatoriale utilisée toutes ses ficelles
réglementaires qu'elle avait à sa
disposition pour rallonger le plus
possible les débats et il faudrait
raconter que la gauche dans cette
entreprise à trébucher à la fin samedi
soir lors du vote finale sur la réforme
des retraites car les sénateurs de
gauche voulaient demander ce qu'on
appelle le Corum du Sénat c'est à dire
compter pour vérifier qu'il y ait bien
une majorité absolue de sénateurs dans
l'hémicycle et auquel cas s'il n'y avait
pas cette majorité absolue et bien
serait reporté d'une heure le vote du
Sénat sur cette réforme de retraite donc
ça aurait un petit peu embêté la droite
sénatoriale et pour que cette demande du
Corum soit valide il fallait 30
signatures de sénateurs de gauche et
bien présenté au président du Sénat et
il y a eu une petite
erreur de tape informatique de la part
d'un collaborateur de gauche et il n'y a
eu que 29 signatures validées donc cette
demande de Corum a échoué voilà donc
voilà petite
erreur à la fin pour la gauche écoute au
final pour la gauche du coup
ça aurait pas empêché probablement le
vote de la réforme et en réalité on est
dans des cours liés à la posture
parlementaire qu'il a encore son son des
cours relativement classique est-ce que
ça peut entraîner une censure du texte
c'est peu probable il y a quand même
dans toute cette procédure législative
des billets d'un constitutionnalité
extrêmement extrêmement fort depuis le
début de l'usage du Pell FSS
rectificatif jusqu'à la façon dont le
gouvernement a fait passer les textes
etc je doute malgré tout le Conseil
constitutionnel emporte une censure
globale et totale du texte pourtant
encore une fois il y a des éléments qui
pourraient être avancés en revanche
là les sénateurs de gauche ils disent
mais maintenant on va porter tout ça
devant le Conseil constitutionnel est-ce
que ça peut aboutir alors encore une
fois sur la sur la procédure globale
théoriquement oui il y a des leviers
LFSS rectificatif le passage du texte un
certain nombre alors ce qu'on pouvait
évoquer sur la vérification du quorum
des recevabilités prononcés sur les
amendements il y a plein de petites
choses qui quand même
[Musique]
probable en revanche on peut avoir un
risque d'avoir très clairement une
censure partielle les cavaliers sociaux
qui émaillent ce texte sur index senior
pénibilité voire certains régimes
spéciaux parce que faut voir que le
PLFSS rectif c'est le principe du de la
vie du Conseil d'État et bien le PLFSS
rectificatif il vise à prévoir les
comptes pour l'année pas pour les 30 ans
qui suivent et donc ce qui n'a pas
d'impact sur les comptes de l'année 2022
et bien théoriquement 2023 théoriquement
ça n'a rien à faire dans un PLFSS rectif
donc là il peut y avoir censure si ça
n'a pas d'impact sur l'année censure de
la mesure phare c'est à dire le report
de parce que là il y a un impact
financier direct et donc comme il y a un
impact financier direct c'est tout
paradoxe en réalité au risque d'avoir
une censure qui supprime le peu de sucré
qui a dans ce texte en revanche la mer
notamment le très amer au regard des
syndicats lui je bois mal comment est-ce
qu'il pourrait être censuré
oui non je pense pas que il y a une
censure globale je pense que
effectivement il va y avoir ici ou là
quelques dispositions qui sont assez
baroques d'ailleurs effectivement
l'index au seniors des choses comme ça
qui peuvent être qui peuvent être
censurés par le Conseil constitutionnel
ça si jamais l'ensemble est extensions
duel ça serait quasiment une révolution
et ça serait aussi une réflexion qui
devrait être menée sur ce quel conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que c'est
d'ailleurs la réflexion existe
dans le cadre de des réformes de la de
la réforme des institutions que veut
conduire le président de la République
il veut qu'il y ait une réflexion sur
cette cette institution savoir est-ce
que c'est une cour suprême à
l'américaine ou ou autre chose c'est
c'est intéressant
il s'est intéressant d'y réfléchir alors
avant de connaître la décision constitue
du Conseil constitutionnel la prochaine
étape c'est cette fameuse commission mix
paritaire puisque mercredi Alex député
sénateurs vont devoir se mettre d'accord
sur un texte commun mais oui Oriane 7
députés cette sénateur vont s'enfermer
dans une salle pour négocier une version
commune de cette réforme des retraites
trouver un compromis alors ce compromis
il est plutôt probable puisque les
parlementaires les républicains et les
parlementaires Renaissance sont
majoritaires dans cette réunion mais les
sénateurs LR l'ont dit ils vont être
ferme dans cette négociation avec la
majorité présidentielle pour garder les
apports du Sénat sur ce texte écoutez
Bruno retaillon ça n'est pas joué
d'avance cette CMP le gouvernement la
majorité présidentielle aurait bientôt
aura bientôt de penser que ce sera
facile les sénateurs croyez-moi nous
avons d'abord en frabloc nous en fera
blocs et on a l'habitude de défendre les
intérêts des Français
voilà Bruno Retailleau qui donne le ton
de cette négociation et s'il y a un
accord qui est trouvé dans cette CMP et
bien jeudi chaque chambre du Parlement
devra voter sur l'ensemble de ce texte
commun de la réforme des retraites et
les yeux seront notamment tournés vers
l'Assemblée nationale ou là la majorité
n'est pas encore acquise avant de parler
du vote il y a du suspense sur le fait
que cette commission mix paritaire
réussissent à trouver un texte commun il
y a toujours du suspense on va dire que
le suspense est assez limité on voit à
peu près comment va finir le film alors
ensuite la question c'est quel va être
la mouture du texte est-ce qu'on a
vraiment un texte qui va être un texte
de compromis qui peut y compris dans les
branches les plus réactives de
renaissance et de du MoDem convaincre
auquel cas ça va avoir une implication
sur l'usage du 49 alinéa 3 ou est-ce que
c'est vraiment un texte qui se fait aux
conditions de LR parce que le
gouvernement n'a pour tout un tas de
raisons pas intérêt à une commission
mixte paritaire qui échouerait auquel
cas ça risque de faire grincer des dents
au MoDem à Renaissance et donc
d'entraîner quelques phénomènes
nécessite au sein de cette majorité qui
peuvent compter et qui peuvent conduire
des factualisage du 49 alinés à 3 sans
même parler des LR etc ça c'est un autre
sujet et il sera probablement
problématique d'arriver là-dessus à
trouver un compromis et de quelle elle
est on pourrait poser la question assez
Olivier merlex qui représentera les
députés les républicains dans cette
commission mix pariétaire il est pas
d'accord sur tout avec ce qu'a voté le
Sénat et avec ce qu'a voter pour une
Retailleau il y a des désaccords
effectivement mais moi je pense pas que
ça soit là que ça se joue je pense que
la commission mixte paritaire ça devrait
ça devrait quand même il devrait trouver
un terrain d'entendre surtout que les
députés représentant la majorité
présidentielle
et les sénateurs d'ailleurs auront
pas intérêt si vous voulez à pousser le
bouchon trop loin je pense qu'ils ont
intérêt à faire passer le texte le mieux
possible alors après moi je pense que le
vrai suspense il sera jeudi après midi à
l'Assemblée nationale où là si on se
pose maintenant et si on fait les
calculs
la majorité elle n'existe pas la
majorité pour le texte n'existe pas et
donc le gouvernement encore trois quatre
jours là pour essayer de persuader des
membres de LR de voter pour le texte et
aussi de s'assurer que le bloc majeur le
bloc de la majorité
est complet est au complet alors que on
sait très bien que il y en a certains
qui pourraient ne pas voter juste pour
revenir sur cette commission mixte
paritaire il y a deux points de
crispation dans les négociations qui
vont être abordés il y a un premier
point de crispation entre les sénateurs
de la républicains et le gouvernement la
majorité présidentielle c'est le CDI
senior le contrat sans cotisation
familiale pour embaucher plus de seniors
que souhaite la droite sénatoriale le
gouvernement n'en veut pas il dit que ça
coûte trop cher 800 millions d'euros le
ministre des comptes publics Gabriel
Attal et compte et puis le deuxième
point de crispation là il concerne
plutôt les sénateurs de la républicains
face aux députés LR et le dispositif car
on a eu des députés LR qui à la fin du
débat à l'Assemblée nationale ont
vraiment défendu cette idée et bien de
43 à nuités pour tout le monde pour ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt alors
que la droite du Sénat dans le débat sur
la réforme des retraites à voter
l'aménagement de ce dispositif carrière
longue mais n'est pas allé jusqu'à 43
annuités pour tout le monde donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a est-ce que c'est aussi de
du texte du fond du texte qui va sortir
de cette CMP que les députés les
républicains vont se décider et que donc
va se jouer de 49-3 ou pas en partie
parce qu'en réalité on a des députés les
républicains on est Olivier marlax en
érection type et ensuite on a des
députés qui sont malgré tout
majoritairement des électrons libres ça
fonctionne certes par courant etc mais
des facto bah c'est pas tout à fait
évident que on est des mobilisations
idem d'ailleurs chez des renaissances et
chez des modem on a vu des voix
discordantes il faut voir que c'est
encore une fois un élément essentiel
pour comprendre ce qui va jouer dans les
prochaines années l'important c'est pas
d'avoir de 189 députés sur papier
la majorité en séance le jour J la nuque
et le RN seront mobilisés ils seront là
a priori est-ce que les députés LR
est-ce que les députés Renaissance
est-ce que les députés modem seront là
ben il y en a qui voteront contre certes
et c'est ceux qui vont être les plus
médiatisés mais il y en a qui tout
bêtement ce jour-là devront aller
d'urgence inaugurée le musée sur le
commerce fluvial dans la tire-t-elle au
XIXe siècle et donc et ils seront pas là
et donc ils vont peut-être donner leur
pouvoir mais pas tous et donc on peut
avoir un jeu de participation
différentiel l'enjeu pour le
gouvernement c'est de s'assurer que 1
tous les membres de sa majorité voteront
que tous les membres de sa majorité
seront présents et que de l'autre côté
une portion raisonnable DLR seront de
manière certaine ici et votre rond c'est
loin loin d'être évident donc le 49
alinéa 3 si vous voulez il est assez
probable ou en tout cas il est loin
d'être impossible il faut voir que pour
l'utiliser vous avez simplement besoin
de délibérer dessus d'en parler lors du
précédent conseil des ministres que ce
soit consigné par le LGG vous n'êtes pas
obligé de faire la publicité vous n'êtes
pas obligé voilà de dire devant le les
journalistes en compte-rendu nous avons
évoqué le 49 finis à trois vous pouvez
le garder pour vous d'ailleurs il a
peut-être été évoqué il y a quelques
conseils des ministres il y a pas besoin
que ce soit mercredi on ne le sait pas
et ensuite ben et Isabelle borne avant
le vote c'est la limite peut déclencher
cet article quand elle veut si jamais
elle voit que dans l'hémicycle ça se
passe bien elle peut s'en abstenir si
jamais elle voit que pas forcément à 15
heures à l'ouverture de la séance
exactement ça peut être plus tard c'est
à n'importe quel moment dans le débat on
peut avoir l'usage du 49 aliné 3 ce qui
laisse au gouvernement et bah une marge
d'appréciation une marge de manœuvre et
pour nous une grande marge de suspense
que le débat sera court si la CMP est
conclusive alors le débat sera court
donc tout va se jouer sur la présence en
réalité au visu est-ce que vraiment la
majorité et là où est-ce qu'elle n'est
pas et politiquement parlant Bruno
Retailleau il a cette phrase il dit
j'aimerais pas être à la place
d'Elizabeth borne elle a le choix entre
la Grosse Bertha et la roulette russe
c'est sûr que il
aimerait pas être à sa place c'est une
formule parce qu'évidemment qu'il
aimerait à sa place
il préférait sans doute à Matignon que
président du groupe LR au Sénat non
c'est vrai que pour elle c'est une
mission délicate mais s'il réussit cette
mission c'est pour elle je dirais la
garantie de probablement rester encore
longtemps à Matignon en revanche si elle
échoue si
ces grilles là là la procédure se grippe
là c'est sûr que pour elle ces jours
seront vraisemblablement
un premier ministre dans une vraie forme
de cette ampleur enfin
supposé de cette ampleur parce que c'est
une réformète en fait on va pas très
loin dans le dans le changement
elle elle fait office de fusible c'est à
dire que le Président de la République
on l'a dit on l'a répété c'est très peu
exprimé sur ce sujet il est resté en
retrait
il a laissé la le Premier ministre être
à la manœuvre et si ça échoue évidemment
que la responsabilité même si les
électeurs
feront un combat c'est très
responsabilité au président de la
République et bien c'est évidemment
c'est vrai que ça va tomber
et il faut voir qu'il y a un enjeu de
gestion de la majorité également on
avait évidemment les yeux rivés sur le
Sénat à raison la semaine dernière mais
il s'est passé des choses à l'Assemblée
le rejet de la PPL horizon la
proposition de loi le fait que la
proposition d'Aurore berger l'a
proposition de loi sur la récidive voilà
c'était sur l'illégibilité
des bancs et vous avez le MoDem qui a
voté contre sur la récidive Renaissance
à voter contre donc on voit que cette
majorité l'entre en exposer façon puzzle
et que donc la gouverner demain tenir
cette majorité va devenir de plus en
plus compliqué on parle des divisions au
sein de LR il y a quasiment plus
d'intergroupes à l'Assemblée dans la
majorité donc si jamais elle perd ce
combat ou si jamais le gagne très
difficilement vient 49 Alina 3 la suite
du quinquennat va être compliqué
tous les matins cette semaine pour
suivre la suite de ce texte
[Musique]